I actually need advice oh please because
I I don't know how
you're a mom yeah I don't know how to be
so fabulous and a mom yeah
I
[Applause]
I mean I I feel like you're like my best
girlfriend because uh like a a creature
with a barely alive libido I look at you
and I'm like she's so hot ah and you're
doing Agatha right now you're Agatha
I love her so much I love a witch I feel
like that this is exactly the pla the
part I should be playing at this stage
in my life and I gotta tell you we got
the hottest coven on the planet in this
show I'm very excited for you all to see
this coming I was grilling you about it
the last time I was like are there any
secrets any spoilers obviously that
Marvel Universe I feel like warns you
yes cannot say a word yes and in fact I
know I know less than I did last time I
I it continues to unfold in ways that
are surprising to me well I can tell you
it's in outer space this time and it is
like that looked like Suburbia yeah
right exactly we keep saying we're just
gonna make up different locales for it
every time we talk about it so this time
it's actually it's just going to be
completely it's going to be a silent
film this time there's going to be no
talking at all in Agatha this time
around watch you in a silent film oh I
could watch you do anything oh what's
wrong
[Applause]
it's true and this new show anyway
[Music]
I'm not so like we could compare
by the way touching your leg you are
shaved okay that's good to know I I
haven't got a little there's a little
bit of but it's fine no no no it's it's
pure as the driven snow okay great it's
perfect this is a whole different ball
game
often like no it took me three months to
finally get to shave yes and I was so
it's like I feel like I
like I had a full-blown movie makeover
just by that me too I I because I have
been like deep in it work wise it's the
let and all clothes have been covering
all that part of my body it's the last
thing I think about and it has been so
liberating yes like I'm like because
like I you know I know summer's around
the corner and blah blah blah blah but
like right now I'm like it's it's all
honestly I shaved for you not knowing
what I was gonna do I think I
subconsciously shaped it
um
your new show
is not only my favorite new show oh true
it's so entertaining but it also pulls
at my heart strings so much it's
emotional it has a very
cool tone like this is not your mother's
show in the sense of like there's a
modernity yeah there's an emotionality
and you're an advice columnist you
become one yes she's not great at she's
she's a you know she's not right in her
real life she's not quite there yet but
through writing these through answering
these letters that she's been receiving
she kind of finds a voice that she
doesn't know that she has now Liz tigler
wrote adapted this book by Cheryl
Strayed called deer called tiny
beautiful things which is a collection
of her advice columns under the name
Anonymous uh title of dear sugar that
she had been writing for this um uh Mag
online magazine called the rumpus for a
long time if it's essential human
reading if you haven't read it it's like
incredible letters and and and and
responses it also made me question like
who is the person giving us advice and
what is their real life like yeah
um and we have a clip let's just take a
look yeah let's just start with how
you're feeling I am feeling hungry I am
feeling tired I'm feeling like a shell
of a person like I'm staring into an
abyss I get it
I mean I'm not there yet but I think
it's really common for women your age to
feel this way I mean you've spoken
before about your insecurities with
getting older I thought we were talking
about me giving money to my brother the
age gap between you and Danny the way
our society treats women over 50 as
irrelevant 49.
thank you
oh my God
Catherine because we are here and I want
to learn how to live a life through the
show like you know I'm not playing a
character I'm me I'm always learning
from everything everybody says for me
too woman I mean I'm just a big old
sponge oh will you get into like deer
sugar and give our audience some advice
I can do the best I
[Applause]
Stars when we come back
[Music]